A mummy is defined broadly
as any well-preserved cadaver,
and has a history that extends
to almost every
continent on the globe.
But when we're talking monsters,
it's hard not to
picture anything
that's not your gauzy,
wrapped, upright human.
Why did the Egyptian mummy
become the poster child
for mummification?
And how did an ancient
common funerary rite
turn into the shambling,
silent, linen-wrapped,
undead corpse monster
of popular culture?
[adventurous music]
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
Mummification was a sacred,
transformative practice
in ancient Egypt.
Directly linked to the
gods Isis and Osiris,
the ritual process made
one's body and soul
fit for existence
in the afterlife.
Part of the mummy's journey
into the stuff of horrors
began with the early
commodification
of Egyptian human remains,
and a little
etymological confusion.
In early modern Asia and Greece,
bitumen was a common
medical remedy.
The Persian word for Bitumen,
became the Latin mumiya,
and later mummie
in medieval Europe.
And with the word mummy
came the mistaken belief
that mummified human corpses
had the same medical
properties as bitumen,
thus creating a corpse
trade where human mummies
were harvested for use
in pharmaceuticals.
By the 16th century,
the controversial trade
became increasingly popular
as people used dead human
remains as medicine.
One English merchant's account
of his handling of
an Egyptian mummy
illustrates the
kind of treatment
the remains were subject to
in this bizarre trade industry.
John Sanderson writes that he
"broke off all
parts of the bodies
to see how the flesh
was turned to drugge,"
bringing home more than
600 pounds of remains
for trade in London
apothecaries.
Some of these specimens
were wholly intact
and pharmacies would unwrap the
bodies for scientific study.
In 1763, John Hadley
unrolled a mummy in his home
at the behest of the
British Royal Society.
His documentation helped lead
to the first systematic study
of Egyptian mummy necropsies
by German physician Johann
Friedrich Blumenbach
in the late 1700s.
For centuries, ancient
Egypt was a subject
of intrigued to Europeans,
and Napoleon's 1798 to
1801 invasion of Egypt
brought back an influx
of pillaged artifacts
and firsthand accounts,
fueling intrigue and sparking
a field of study, Egyptology.
This marked the first grips
of Egyptomania in
the 19th century,
a term used to summarize
the robust popular interest
in ancient Egyptian culture.
Ancient Egypt continued
as a fashionable pursuit
in the first decade
of the 19th century,
mostly in Britain.
The British government
built its own Egyptian Hall,
which housed artifacts
transferred to Britain
as part of Napoleon's surrender.
The public even
started to collect
cheap replicas of
Egyptian furniture,
china patterns inspired
by Egyptian designs,
and other commercial items.
The 1820s brought
significant contributions
to the mummy monster as well.
Former circus strongman
Giovanni Belzoni's
recreation of an Egyptian tomb
in Piccadilly's Egyptian
Hall In 1821 drew crowds,
as did his inventive
marketing techniques,
which included public
mummy autopsies.
He was occasionally assisted
by the surgeon and
antiquarian Thomas Pettigrew,
who would become a
famous Egyptologist
and celebrity mummy autopsist
the following decade after
his 1834 publication,
"History of Egyptian Mummies,"
considered the foundational
text in modern mummy studies.
In 1822, John-Francois
Champollion
translated hieroglyphics
for the first time
using the Rosetta Stone.
Desire to better understand
all aspects of ancient
Egyptian culture,
including its dead, grew.
Attempts to identify the name
and social status of mummies
became increasingly important.
In 1825, Augustus
Bozzi Granville
performed the first modern
medical autopsy of a mummy.
The mummy continued to
turn up in hospitals,
artist studios, dissection
theaters, universities,
and on the drawing room
tables of the upper class.
Unrolling or unwrapping mummies
was both an academic pursuit
and a form of titillating
entertainment.
Members of the public
who could not attend
such a spectacle in person
had their appetites whet
with detailed reports
of the experience in newspapers.
When you consider how
the removal of the corpse
from its intended resting place
turns it more
object than person,
the treatment of the mummified
corpse as entertainment
is significant in
understanding the mummy.
They are made uneasy
representations of culture,
history, and personhood,
something fiction responds
to by making them monsters.
Jane Loudon is the first author
to write these tensions
into a fictional text.
Her 1827 science fiction
novel, "The Mummy!
Or A Tale of the
Twenty-Second Century,"
is the story of a
reanimated Egyptian mummy.
In the long, bizarre tale,
the Mummy Cheops
serves as a terrifying
yet instructive
undead character.
The book was incredibly
commercially popular
and reprinted multiple times.
The influence of imperialism
contributed to the
commodification
and fetishization
of the mummy in Britain.
Colonial territories in
other distant countries
provided museums and
private collections
with a steady stream of exotic
items, including bodies.
By mid-century, the
unwrapping of a mummy
had become both formulaic
and highly performative.
The body would be
laid surrounded
by other Egyptian artifacts
and funerary images.
A lecture about the
practice of mummification
and Egyptian history would serve
as a prelude to the real show,
the removal of the textiles
and other items on the body.
Some of these items, an amulet,
a fragment of bandage,
a piece of bone,
might be passed around
for the audience
to touch, smell, even taste.
In some cases, particularly
at private unrolling parties,
the guests may keep the
objects as souvenirs.
We see this trend dramatized
in mummy fiction of the time.
In French author
Theophile Gautier's story,
"The Mummy's Foot,"
a man buys a mummified foot
and later a woman hopping on
one foot arrives at his door.
She's an ancient
Egyptian princess
searching for her
lost appendage,
apparently unable to rest until
her full body is restored.
Edgar Allen Poe's
1845 short story,
"Some Words with a Mummy,"
sets the reanimated
Egyptian corpse
in an all too familiar place,
the white man's
unwrapping party.
The mummy at the
center of the story
is brought back to life
with an electrical charge
to the outright
terror of the guests.
Louisa May Alcott is responsible
for what many consider
to be the first
mummy's curse narrative,
"Lost in a Pyramid;
or, The Mummy's Curse."
Penned in 1868, a mummified
Egyptian sorceress
curses anyone who dares
to disturb her grave,
which, of course,
two British men do.
Famous mummy fiction at
the turn of the century,
like Arthur Conan Doyle's
"The Ring of Thoth"
and "Lot No. 249,"
or Bram Stoker's "The
Jewel of Seven Stars"
helped bolster the
already mysterious
and mystical popular perception
of the Egyptian dead.
The rise of the film industry
continues to reinforce the
mummy as foreign antagonist.
In the 1899 silent film
"Robbing Cleopatra's Tomb,"
the mummy makes its first
appearance on screen.
A man chops a female
mummy into pieces
in order to resurrect her.
In 1911's "The Mummy,"
a female mummy comes to life
after exposure
to an electrical current.
The Egyptian princess
is infatuated with
the male protagonist
and aggressively pursues him,
reinforcing the
whole Egyptian mummy
as fetish commodity thing.
The 1920s popularized the
idea of the mummy's curse.
Although 19th century writers
had already used this trope,
now the idea was supported
by rumors of a real curse.
The rumor of King Tutankhamun's
curse is notorious,
in part because some people
associated with the excavation
did die in mysterious ways.
When archeologist Howard Carter
and his patron the
5th Earl of Carnarvon
unburied the immense tomb of
King Tut in November 1922,
it was an immediate
global sensation,
sparking a new
period of Egyptomania
that would grow into
a fever pitch in 1923
when Lord Carnarvon fell ill
from an infected mosquito bite,
after rumors circulated
that he had stolen
a hoard of
valuable items from the dig.
Even before the
lord's eventual death
from complications
of the infection,
stories circulated that he was
suffering a dire punishment
for opening and robbing
the Egyptian king.
While not the first
rumored mummy's curse,
King Tut's was the curse
with the most bodies
attributed to it,
at least 12 if you include
some unfortunate pets.
Real warnings do adorn the
walls of Egyptian tombs.
Meant to deter thieves
and keep the resting
place of the dead sacred,
these hieroglyphics
never translate
to vengeful undead corpses.
In fact, in ancient
funerary tradition,
the bones of the deceased
would be broken
to prevent them from rising
and walking among the living.
Life after death was one
thing for the Egyptians,
disturbing the living
in this realm, however,
was not encouraged.
Besides the fact that
rumors of mummy curses
make for profitable
tabloid fodder
and easy inspiration
for gothic tales,
it's important to note
that during this period,
Egypt was actively
seeking independence
from British colonial rule.
Painting the physical
and bodily remains
of the ancient Egyptians
in a negative way
attempted to
discredit and demonize
the living Egyptian population.
While the film can be
read in several ways,
it's hard to deny
the cultural impact
of Universal Pictures'
1932 "The Mummy."
Inspired in part by the
preceding decades' events
as well as 19th century
gothic and horror tales,
the film tells the story of
an undead Egyptian priest
desperate to secure
the woman he believes
to be the reincarnation
of his one-time lover.
"The Mummy" is an
interesting commentary
on the curse controversy
around the opening
of King Tut's tomb,
one that places science
as a dangerous pastime,
at least when it comes
to disturbing corpses.
Included with the
remains of Imhotep,
the mummy at the
center of the film,
is a box emblazoned
with a curse.
Archeologist Whemple ignores
occult scientist Professor
Muller's call for caution,
declaring, "In the
interest of science,
even if I believe in the curse,
I'd go on with my
work for the museum."
Although it's the
archeologist's assistant
who inadvertently brings
the mummy back to life,
the commentary on
the selfish pursuit
of scientific advancement
and the folly of youth
cannot be missed.
And in the end it is magic,
or rather, the movie's
warped interpretation
of ancient Egyptian
spiritual practices
that defeats the mummy.
But what really made
the movie iconic,
Boris Karloff's bandaged form.
Even though the titular
mummy in the movie
only spends a few
minutes on screen
wrapped in linen bandages,
appearing in the
rest of the film
as a modern Egyptian historian,
the compelling image animated
the mummy's public form
in a way unseen since those
early 19th century necropsies.
Yet it wasn't until the 1940s
that the mummy became
a true horror monster.
Where the Egyptian undead
had before
been more moralistic,
romantic, or profound,
even if they were placed
in tension with
Western protagonists,
this decade of horror films
made them something to fear.
Their decay was
made more profound,
often with wrappings
still in place,
and they ambled about
seemingly void of all emotions
other than anger and revenge.
We see this trend take hold
in Universal's second
foray into mummy horror,
"The Mummy's Hand."
Unable to secure Karloff
for an official sequel
to their 1932 film,
Universal gets creative with
the story...and the costuming.
With an aim to capitalize
on audience recognition,
they put the new actor
in a rubber mask,
made the mummy mute,
and kept him wrapped in
bandages for most of the movie.
The odd shambling walk
that the Egyptian mummy
would become known for?
The replacement actor
Tom Tyler had arthritis.
They gave the mummy
a new backstory
to partially explain
these physical changes,
getting rid
of the articulate mummy
and replacing him
with a silent thief,
cursed to be
an uncontrollable monster.
The movie's sequel,
"The Mummy's Tomb" in 1942,
reinforced the silent
shambling version of the mummy,
and Universal will double down
on the image in the 1950s,
but for the first time,
throw in some humor as well
with "Abbott and
Costello Meet the Mummy."
Just like the
advent of Egyptology
and the medical autopsy
provided inspiration
for tales some
hundred years before,
scientific advancements
in the 1950s
also found their way
into mummy myths.
The greater prevalence
of x-rays in archeology
and the use of chemical testing
meant that the Egyptian
mummy could be examined
in a way previously unheard of.
Gone are the spells
or galvanic batteries
that bring the mummy to life.
Science's ability to
solve the mysteries
of life and death
become paramount,
not that such
scientific advances
weren't again met
with trepidation.
"Curse of the Faceless Man"
claims radiation
from x-ray exposure
is what revives the mummy.
Another trend that arises,
conflating the mummy with
other undead monsters,
In the "Pharaoh's Curse,"
the disturbance of the
remains of an Egyptian priest
leads to a character
being possessed
by the soul of the mummy.
The character, aided by
a shapeshifting cat woman,
begins rapidly aging and
starts sucking people's blood
before becoming
the mummy himself.
Since then, the mummy has
been a familiar horror figure
in the pages of fiction,
children's cartoons,
movies across genres, and on
the front of cereal boxes.
They've been made frequent
characters in comic books,
ravenous zombie-esque
flesh eaters,
and Brendan Fraser's
sinewy nemesis.
The Egyptian mummies
that stalk the pages
and screens of horror,
science fiction, and fantasy
are in a way justified
for their behavior.
Rarely does a mummy animate
without outside provocation,
and many of those bodies
are exposed to modernity
by the mistakes or
greed of the living.
They threaten to
literally consume or kill
those who see them as objects
ready for commercial consumption
or scientific investigation.
Part of what makes the
Egyptian mummy horrifying
or monstrous outside
of its intended context
is a lack of understanding
associated with a death practice
few people are familiar with,
and mistreatment of those
bodies by outsiders.
Before you go,
we want to invite you
to participate in
PBS Digital Studios'
annual audience survey.
It's your chance
to tell PBS what you like
and even vote
on new show ideas.
If you'd like to continue
shaping the future of PBS
There's a link in the
description below.
We can't wait
to hear from you.
Dramaticized.
(speaker)
Dramatized.
Dramatized, okay!
Oh, is it Thoth?
I did it right! [groaning]
Carna, Carnarvon.